hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled how to streamline your
variant classification workflow with
hgmd this webinar is part of the
clinical diagnostics and research event
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and sponsored by
kyogen for more information about our
sponsor visit them at
kyogen.com let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our live chat feature in the
presentation you can find that live chat
at the right of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you might have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many quest
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just simply
click on that help desk button located
at the bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby
finally
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits without
further ado i now present today's
speaker molina gaddis from the clinical
field application scientist at kyogen
digital insights for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen
dr gaddis welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you to the kaijan digital insights
webinar on how to streamline your
variant classification workflow with the
human gene mutation database or hcmd
my name is mega balanado and i will be
your host and moderator for today
during the presentation please use the
ask a question box on the right of the
slide window to post your questions to
our speaker and kaijun experts which
will then be answered throughout the
session
we will also have a q a at the end of
the presentation
please also check out our resources
section for important links
with that i would like to introduce our
speaker for today dr melania gaddis
melina garris is a clinical field
application scientist at kyogen digital
insights with previous experience as a
variant interpretation scientist
and now i will hand the presentation
over to milena thank you
thank you mega
and thank you all for joining today as
we talk about different ways that hgmd
can help streamline your variant
classification workflow
i'd first like to go over the overview
of what we're going to be discussing
today
first we're going to talk about what the
human gene mutation database is hdmd
and then also some advantages of hdmd
professional
and then i would like to walk you
through some examples and use cases that
i've encountered previously as a variant
scientist
that have really
been
good illustrators of how hdmd is a
valuable tool to help with variant
research
and then as megan mentioned we will have
a q a session
so first what is the human gene mutation
database
it is an expert curated database of
human germline mutations from
peer-reviewed published journals
drawing your attention to this figure on
the right
you can see an analysis between the
content in hdmd
omim and clinvar
and nearly 60 percent of the clinvar
entries at this point in time are found
within hdmd
this remaining 36 000
is likely not an hgmd because clinvar
does not necessarily require users
who are submitting their clinical
assertions about a variant
to
have specific guidelines for
evidence to support that assertion
and so
we like to say if it's not published
it's not an hdmd
you can also see that
hdmd has quite a bit of content
that is not available in either omim or
clinvar and so really it's a great tool
if you're asking the question
does this human germline mutation cause
disease
i'd like to note that hdmd is for
germline mutations only not for somatic
many of you are probably aware that
there is a publicly available version of
hgmd
i'd like to just take a moment and talk
about some of the advantages of having a
professional version
one of the main ones being that with a
professional hdmd version
there are quarterly updates
where information is recovered for more
than 2000 different journals and this is
done manually by
genetics experts who are actually
reviewing all of this literature
in this table on the right i have some
statistics between
the second quarter release of this year
for hdmd
and the third quarter release
and you can see just between the two
quarters there's quite a bit of content
um thousand you know twenty thousand
thirty thousand variants that are added
just within one quarter
and i'd like to note that with the
publicly available version
the content is three years
out of date and so you can see
having this
professional version you get the most
up-to-date
uh clinical information for these
variants
the hdmd entries will include the first
example of the mutation where it was
published in the effect
and additionally there may be
more reports
pubmed entries that are either
functional studies
or publications that indicate
alternative phenotypes
information that may be useful to the
user
and so there are a couple of ways that
you can access this information
first off with the advanced um
with the hdmd professional version you
have advanced search capabilities that
are not necessarily available with the
public version
you have availability to search by gene
or mutation you can do phenotype
searches
and you can look at these mutation
overviews for specific genes to get an
idea of the number of
mutations by variant
type also
there is an availability of a
downloadable version of hdmd
professional
so if you prefer to have the data in tab
delimited files
or a mysql relational database that's
also available
so now that we've talked about
what hd gmd is i'd like to now move on
to some examples where hdmd has been
particularly useful
as i've done variant research in the
past
specifically talking about you know
doing the research of a variance
clinical insignificance
some ways that visualizing variants
through hdmd
can provide information about
uh the allele of interest that you're
looking at
ways to identify genes associated with
specific phenotypes
and then using some of the advanced
capabilities to design an ngs panel
and so my first use case is for a
variant
in the gene that has kind of a
difficult
naming scheme it's got legacy and
alternative names that can make research
kind of difficult
this gene is serpent a1 and in this use
case you know a variant scientist would
be given this variant to look over and
to research
and given the hgvs the human genome
variation society nomenclature for this
variant
i want to present what a workflow might
look like
so for this variant the user may go to
clinvar first and because you don't
necessarily want to take the entries in
clinvar at face value
you dig a little deeper into the entry
and you see the associated literature
for that variant
however there's no mention of any
alternative names
uh or other schemes within this clinvar
entry
and so you're looking up this steering
to
codon six to change to leucine
and
so you pull up this literature
information that was associated with the
clinvar entry
and when you investigate
this pubmed you see that within this
paper the only serene to losing change
is happening at codon minus 19.
you also notice that this is somehow
also associated with something called
p-i-z-rexim
so at this point you're not seeing any
mention of a serine 6 leucine
so you may move on to the gene review
for serpent a1 where you indeed confirm
that alpha a1
alpha 1 antitrypsin deficiency is the
associated phenotype
and you get a little bit of background
information about the gene you see that
variants were initially described based
on electrophoretic protein variants with
the prefix
pi denoting protease inhibitor
so essentially they would
add this pi
in conjunction with the name of the
location where this variant was
identified and this was all before they
knew that serpent a1 was the associated
gene
and so you have
not only what appears to be like a
legacy name
where the codon is different but you
have this different alternative naming
scheme based on
the location of where the variant was
found
but still at this point you're not quite
sure that you can confirm
that serine 6 leucine is in fact the
same variant as the serine minus 19
leucine
you take a look at the omim entry
and you kind of get the same information
the same literature is associated the
same names are given
however you still don't have any
confirmation
that this is the variant you're looking
at you suspect it is but to be certain
at this point you would have to do
additional digging
to confirm
that the information you're finding
is relevant to the variant you're
researching
i would propose going to hdmd as your
first step in your variant
classification workflow because it's
going to provide you that background
information and save you time
that you where you don't need to go and
research these historic or alternate
naming schemes
so here i'm showing a browser view of
the online version
where i searched by gene serbin e1
and i've looked at miss sense variants
and within the first entry i see
the variant i'm interested in is serine
6 leucine
and conveniently hdmd has a special
column
that describes the legacy change
and you can see that there's an offset
by 24 amino acids
explaining why
you're seeing this minus 19. it was
probably part of a translocation signal
or something and the original
people studying
started counting 24
codons downstream
and so
i have con confirmation and i can click
on this hgmd accession here
to view the variant entry and in this
variant entry
again i get confirmation that the
associated disease or phenotype is
alpha-1 anti-trypsin deficiency
hdmd considers this a disease-causing
mutation
again i have the codon number
and the legacy codon number available in
this view
and i have the primary literature report
for the first time experiment was
published as well as an additional
report
and so at this point i can be confident
that when i'm talking about
this serine six leucine
it's the same thing mentioned in this
primary literature
because the geneticists who are
reviewing the information and updating
the content within hdmd will not
associate literature if there's any
ambiguity
they will in fact follow up with the
authors of the publication if there's
any question
so they've done that
background digging for you saving you
time
so that you can move forward with your
research
i have another example i'd like to show
in another gene
this time you're looking at the gene gne
and you're looking at an arginine 297
glutamine change
and in and i'd like to break out of the
presentation and show you a live
example
of how you could do this type of search
within
the online version of hdmd
go ahead and log in
go to online and you're first brought to
the home page for humd where you can see
the current version
the contents and any important
announcements or updates
and so there's a number of ways i can
search i could search by gene if i
wanted to look at all the variants
within the gene g and e
and then narrow it down by missense
i could do that
until i find the one i'm interested in
i'd like to show you another way where
you can more directly pull up this
information
here in this mutation search you can
search by the codon
if you have the hdmdx session you could
directly look db snip
i'm going to use the coordinate
so using the chromosome and coordinate
i can paste it in here
and important to remember that there's a
drop down where you kind of specify how
you're searching and you also want to
specify if you're doing this by
coordinate which genome build and i'm
working in hd 38 so i'll go ahead and
i'll submit my query
and it directly pulls up
my variant that i'm interested in
and so if i wanted to i could also click
on the gene symbol and get that same
spectrum of mutations that i could find
by searching this way
how i could link out to dbsnp
i would like to review the accession
and so pulling up the succession
i say that the associated phenotype is
siluria
and again
the hgmd entry is fighting this is a
disease mutation
i don't see anything in the codon number
about a legacy
naming scheme
and so then my attention is then taken
to
the literature there's a couple of
different
papers the first one being reported
in a portuguese
girl who had the clinical biochemical
and molecular characteristics
additional papers were added because
the reviewers found that there was good
information useful information
that they added
and i want to draw your attention here
to the comments
and the notes something that i have
found particularly helpful at many times
is that reviewers will add
these notes that clarify things for
example
we're looking for something at codon 297
but within the paper it's indicating
that it's an arginine 266 glutamine
um again another
uh note in another public about another
publication
it's reported the same way and it gives
ensemble transcript
also helpful is many times the the
comment will tell you kind of where to
look for the variant
so if it's only listed in the
supplemental they'll point you in that
direction
and
it it also shows the value and having
someone manually look at the information
and they're not just reviewing the text
the body of the text they're able to
look at you know graphs and figures
uh they look at you know supplemental
table supplement information
and then they kind of point you to where
they found that key piece of information
for the variant
and so here you know that there's
a reporting scheme on a different
transcript than the one
you've been given
and so hdmd the web version has
this
additional predicted hdbs descriptor
feature
where it will list all of the refseq
transcripts the hgbs descriptors
as well as the ensemble
and so you know you can you know match
it up that 815
and from here it gives the c dot that
you can confirm
that the 797 g to a
is actually
this 266 q if you translate it to
amino acid
and so here's another example where
uh you know first reviewing the hdmd
entry
gives you key insights that will help
you as you continue with your literature
review now if i were to go and look for
additional literature
i would know that there's a possibility
it could be reported a number of
different ways and so i need to be aware
when i'm doing that search and how i
form that search and so
you know at this point we've talked
about how hdmd can help you with your
variant research and save you time along
the way
and so moving on i would like to talk a
little bit about some of
the use cases for
visualizing this data
and for downloading the data
so
many people
when they download the hdmd
vcf file
we'll we'll
convert it to
the vcf from hdmd
and annotate their variants and um one
you know use case for doing that is that
you know sometimes when you do
sequencing you'll get a large list of
variants and you want to narrow down
to look at those that are most likely to
be clinically significant
and so you can filter by things like a
little frequency or quality metrics but
you could also annotate with hdmd
and filter down
that way as well
to to come up with a smaller list
of variants to look at in more detail
so
another use case for that downloadable
vcf is for visualization purposes and so
why is this helpful
sometimes you want to see what's in the
genomic neighborhood what we like to
call the genomic neighborhood and
this could be
visualizing a vcf track for your variant
of interest
and being able to see if there are
entries within hdmd that are at the same
codon
and that are marked as
disease mutations or supposed disease
mutations
and having this visual representation
for many users is quite helpful
other times you may find visualization
helpful if you're looking at a
particular
region of a gene for example if you're
at the three prime end
and you're looking at frame shifts and
if you have something that's past
the boundary for nonsense mediated decay
you need additional evidence from
the literature or functional studies
showing that
that last part of the protein has
significance if it's
cut off and so being able to see
visually an hdmd track
showing other reported
disease mutations in that location will
point you to some of that evidence
another use case that i find helpful
is having the hdmv track loaded to help
confirm that my secondary
analysis is accurately calling or
describing variants
so i have a case here
that i've uploaded into the ucsc genome
browser
it's within the apc gene
and i'm at a region where there's a
little bit of repetition with this agag
motif
and
my variant of interest is here in purple
and you can see that there's a little
dash on top followed by the ga on the
bottom
indicating that you have an assertion
of a ga
and i can see by loading the hdmg track
on top
which is what all these bearings on the
top are
in blue
i have
a
an insertion of a ga
that's nearby or in the genomic
neighborhood
and
so as a as a person you know
reviewing this variant and
maybe examining
the bed file or the bam the reads
um i might be suspect i might suspect
that
this insertion
is in fact supposed to be
called here
a few bases away
downstream
because in repetitive regions sometimes
there can be
uh changes in
how it's represented in the vcf versus
hgbs
and so i would know to follow up
maybe with finger confirmation
to make sure that this is in fact the
variant i want to look at
and that it doesn't need to be
altered in my secondary analysis to
actually reflect
something that's been recorded in the
literature
as a disease mutation
so you can see how
having this visualization
makes
this type of analysis quick
and just briefly
i'd like to go over kind of how
you'd go about that process of uploading
so when you have a professional license
for an hdmd download you have a number
of different files that are available to
you
um
i'm highlighting here
the the vcf the zipped vcf in hd 38 also
available in hd19
so you would just download that
and then
many individuals will use integrative
genomics viewer rgb or the ucsc genome
browser
a lot of times personal preference
just to give you an idea of what an
upload of this bcf looks like in igv
i've loaded it here
and then oops
i've
blown up the
information here
so this is information parsed from the
vcf file
and so
you can see
the gene and the phenotype
the hgvs nomenclature
maybe
the vcf format is not supported as well
in igb it has this little percentage
but you can get the key information here
i tend to prefer using the ucsc genome
browser
i like that
you can see the
the nature of the
variant change
so you can see
if it's a deletion
or if you have an insertion
um you can also see if you have you know
like gtt
large cmvs
it provides just a little bit more
information
and so this is kind of what
the parsed information from the vcf
would look like
we do have versions that are
specifically formatted
for the
ucsc genome browser that provides the
full entry that's available with our
genome tracks product
just as an fyi
and so i have some additional use cases
that i'd like to actually show
so i'm going to move out
powerpoint
and
my first one
i'll pull up so just briefly it's
relatively easy to upload a vcf
within the ucsd genome browser you would
go to my data
custom tracks
and then within here you would add
custom tracks and then there's just a
quick upload
and this you can save your session so if
you don't want to have to reload every
time
you pull up the information it will save
all of these settings and configurations
so i have here
in the
this apc variant that i initially showed
here is my variant of interest in purple
there's a dash at the top so an
insertion of an a g
in this repetitive region
and so i can load my my reads file
and
determine if my variant calling pipeline
needs to be adjusted or if this is in
fact a novel
variant in the individual
another use case for
having this information in this visual
format
is if you're doing like variant
classification
according to acmg guidelines
one
piece of information or evidence
here i have my variant of interest in
the gene pah
which is a g to t
i can quickly see that at this same
location there have been disease
mutations
reported in hgmd
for g to c and g to a
and so this is something that as part of
acmg you can
use as a piece of evidence if
these are then shown to be pathogenic
that tells you that you know this codon
has some sort of functional importance
um
and and so having this kind of
neighborhood view
to see kind of what's upstream or
downstream can be very helpful at times
and
so you know now that we've talked about
some of the applications for using a
downloadable vcf
i'd like to move on to some other use
cases
here
for
when you may want to identify genes
associated with a specific phenotype
you know if you're
more on the research side
and you're interested in
discovering what genes are associated
with the phenotype
in this case you know bipolar disorder
within the online user interface
we have the ability to search by
phenotype
so then all i would have to do is i
could do a boolean search where
it will pull in the actual entries with
the term bipolar disorder
and search within hdmd phenotypes
and i can quickly
find
for the associated bipolar disorder
phenotypes within hdmd
a list of genes
that have you know associated literature
indicating some sort of relevance or
impact
with this phenotype
and so this is a good place to start if
there's you know additional
places i want to take my research i i
have this list to follow up on
another use case um might be to utilize
the content within hdnd
to design a panel maybe based on
phenotype maybe i want to design
a panel for cardiomyopathy
so in this case you would do an advanced
search
and i'll actually do kind of a
demonstration showing the search but
but what you would get is a list of the
variants within hdmd that are associated
with cardiomyopathy
oops sorry about that and so i'll i'll
skip out now and do
and show you kind of how i did that
search
so i went to advanced
and within advanced i went to
nucleotide substitution
plus
and within this page
i'm interested in
searching by disease phenotype
but you have a number of different
parameters that you can include in your
search if you wanted to search by
functional elements
maybe if you're doing research and
you want to look at variants within
known transcription factor binding sites
that could be particularly useful motif
search
if you're looking for specific you know
splice variants or regulatory regions
i kind of want to look at it all
so i so i've highlighted
my output file the information that i
want to receive back
i want to get that mutation variant db
snip
and i i've specified my genome build
and so
i'm just going to specify cardiomyopathy
and then hit submit
and at this point it pulls up that table
and i can actually download the bed file
that you can then load into ucsc
and then you can visualize across all of
the associated genes with cardiomyopathy
the known variants so if you then wanted
to go and design targets for a panel
you could make sure they're covering all
of these associated hdmd entries
you can also click here to save it as a
text file
and so then you pull this up
probably looks better in excel but you
have all of
this information
that was brought forward
which is displayed here a nice tabular
format but you have that option to
export it and save it
and so
hopefully you know i've been able to
show
that hdmd has a lot of utility for for
varying classification
and um
and that it can really speed up your
process by giving you that information
about historical or legacy names
different transcripts
so you can
quickly get through your literature
search and get to your answer
and you know there's different ways that
you can use the data to to visualize or
to annotate
to help with other aspects of
analysis
and
you have up you have many different
options for
uh
searching for this information you know
by phenotype
um
and in that advanced search where you
can actually export and then
move on to help design a panel based on
a phenotype
so
you know thank you for your attention
and for listening and i'd be happy to
take any questions at this point thank
you for that informative presentation
milena
with that let's straight away jump into
q a
uh i see a lot of questions coming
my first question would be how often is
html updated
so htmd is updated on a quarterly basis
okay
second question
is there an applaudable vcf with more
information included from the hdmd entry
yes so with the download of genome
tracks
which you can
license
you have a number of different files
that are specifically formatted
for
uh upload into ucsc
and there's different ways you can do
the html you can view by like phenotype
and
by disease mutation or functional
polymorphism
so so yes that is definitely available
great
next question would be
does hdmd provide information about
genomic polymorphisms in genes
yes so
for a polymorphism
to
be
included in hgmd
there is some sort of literature
evidence
showing
a link to disease
or a phenotype
and so
polymorphisms can be added to hdmd
okay we have some time left to take a
few more questions
um next one which genome build is used
for hdmd
so hdmd has been
updated for hd 38
and most of you know the information is
presented that way
however there is still support for hd19
so that you can also see that
information if that's the build you're
using
okay
why are there articles for a specific
variant that have not been captured in
hdmd but can be found using other search
tools such as google scholar pubmed
etc
right so so you will note that
there are just a few articles shown and
and really the aim of hdmd is to show
the primary report that first report for
the variant is um
published in the literature
and
the additional articles are really only
added if there's something new
or important that they add for example
an updated phenotype
or
um functional evidence talking about you
know protein structure
and and so the goal of hdmd is to not
necessarily return
all of the possible information
available for a variant but to give you
that
key background that's important
and so so that's why you're gonna find
those key pieces of information rather
than
every single publication
for that variant
next one
do we have to pay extra to download the
data from hvmd
if you already have hdmd pro
yes so the hdmd online version and the
hdm
hdmd download are both part of different
licenses
and so uh you can consult with a
customer representative to
see what the price difference may be to
add the download to
the online version of the license
okay we have three more questions
um in hmd does it provide the
information or evidence of its variant
classification
so hgnd is technically not classifying
variants in the terms of acmg
but they will give
an
annotation of a disease-causing mutation
or a dm
or if it's suspected to be a
disease-causing mutation it'll have dm
question mark
and so the evidence
is within those publications
and the curators who are reviewing this
evidence
always err on the side of adding
something
rather than leaving it out if there's
any question about its association with
disease so that in future publications
come out
this variant is kind of flagged for
um further
review
so that it can be you know revised in
the future as more evidence becomes
available
great
should we be refreshing vcf's upload
from hdmd to ucsc every quarter
yes so every quarter
when the new version of hgmt
professional comes out there will be
substantial additions
and new uh mutations that are added to
the database so i think it would be a
good idea
to upload
the new vcf each quarter just so that
you're reflecting those new additions
to hdmd
and the last question of the session is
uh html integrated into qci if so is it
the full version of hmd or the public
version
yes so qci is qci hydrogen clinical
insights interpret and it's
a software that assists in variant
interpretation
and so with the license of qci interpret
um you are able to see the full hdmd
entry for
the version for the variant that you're
looking at
so
what this means is if you wanted to
search for nearby variants
those hdmd entries wouldn't necessarily
show up as part of
qci interpret you would need the
additional license
but for every variant in your vcf that
goes through interpret for which there's
an hdmd
entry you will be able to view that
entry as part of
interpret
all right
before we conclude i would like to thank
our speaker dr molina garris and most of
all you our audience for your attention
we hope this was informative and helpful
however if you should have any remaining
questions please do not hesitate to
contact us we are here to help you
this concludes today's session on htmd
we look forward to hosting you in future
kaijan digital insights webinars
have a pleasant rest of your day thank
you